هل حصل بنت فيرا على ما يريد نعم الاتفاق
واعتبرته وقياده اسرائيليه وصمتعار وان
بالكفير هو رئيس الوزراء وليس نتنياهو لكن
لماذا
تقلقوا والصلاحيات الواسعه قيادات
اسرائيليه وما يطال منها الجيش الاسرائيلي
واعتبر ذلك تاسيسا لعمل الجيش فتغير
مرجعيه حارس الحدود من الجيش الى بنت فيري
يعني اول تاثيرا على الجيش والتداخل في
الصلاحيات بين المؤسسه العسكريه وحرس
الحدود ولعل ما يخشاه القاده العسكريون
اطل براسه جندي اسرائيلي يهدد النشطاء
تضامن ومع اهل الخليل المثير في مقاله
اهدر
مشاهد
الغربيه الغربي
بين فارع يدرك هو ان المضيئه بسرعه كبيره
في تنفيذ اجنته له عواقب لذا فالرجل يمضي
بحذر ويحذر انصاره اذا هو تكيف مع المرحله
المقبله سواء من بنفيرو وانصاره او حتى من
بقيه اجهزه الدوله ومؤسساتها وبدا هذا
واضحا فيما اتخذته مفاوضات السجون
الاسرائيليه من اجراء باقاله قائد السجن
جلبوع في اعقاب اخفاقات كوشي عنها في سجون
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي وعمليه نفق الحريه
التي نفذها سته اسرى فلسطينيين وفروا من
السجن في سبتمبر من العام الماضي اجراءات
تستبق وصوله بنك
لتتكيف مع خطط وزير الامن القومي المقبل
من الواضح ان البنك يتجه نحو مزيدا من
التشدد في السجون وفرد المزيد من القيود
على الاسرى
تسميه النائب المتطرف ايثمار بن كبير
وزيرا للامن القومي في اسرائيل بمثابه من
يضع القط لحراسه اللبن براي مراقبين في
اسرائيل فهو سيكون مسؤولا عن حرس الحدود
في الضفه الغربيه المحتله لقد يشعل الوضع
اكثر هناك والاخطار بانه مسؤول عن الشرطه
الاسرائيليه واقتحامات المسجد الاقصى لان
مخططه وتقسيم المكان والسماح للمتطرفين
اليهود بصلاته هناك ما قد يشعل حربا على
قطاع غزه وان لم يكن ذلك كافيا فقد يؤدي
الى توتر الاوضاع داخل اسرائيل بين اليهود
والعرب واكثر من ذلك سيوتر العلاقه اكثر
بين نتنياهو والاداره الامريكيه